they're gonna line this very piecey day
and age I love a movie that's made for
kids it's probably gonna mess him up a
little bit like that the boxtrolls
so boxtrolls is a stop animation
claymation type movie which there are
these little boxtrolls and live in the
sewers and they come up at night and
take knickknacks and they steal from
people and there were the upper-class
people who are all like we taste
cheese's cheese and there's this really
creepy guy who wants to be in with the
upper-class he wants to taste cheese
with everyone so he wants to wipe out
the boxtrolls and there's this kid who
was raised by the boxtrolls and of
course he's gonna unite the boxtrolls
and the people if this really bad guy
doesn't get in the way and you know how
those movies gonna go by watching this
movie the first half of the movie I was
like I don't know if I'm filling this
movie to be honest with you know it's
kind of slow is a lot of buildup and I
like the animation for sure I like
stop-motion animation because everything
you see now is CGI it's all computer
animated so when you see a style that
kind of harkens back to the old days
it's just cool to see like Princess and
the Frog you see it you're like I I do
like hand-drawn that's cool grandma
there's some CGI in this movie too it's
a hybrid of the two but for the most
part it's really cool to see the
stop-motion the second half of the movie
really picked up for me and then I was
like oh I'm having a good time with this
movie this is actually cool the villain
was a really gross and messed up guy you
know you feel for the boxtrolls you look
oh you guys man you got the bad rap
you're just really cool goblins don't
know why they don't like you oh wait
it's probably a metaphor for the
upper class and lower class of
civilization all right and then the last
act of the movie is really exciting you
know you're having a good time with this
movie but you do look at it and you're
like guy it's made for kids I don't know
if they're gonna walk out as movie like
I'm the same exact kid I was before I
went into that movie nothing affected me
at all but I do like it just today my
friends and I were talking we were
talking about movies that we Revere as
good from our childhoods and some of
them had really creepy disturbing
imagery like labyrinth
Dark Crystal Wrath of Khan traffic on
wasn't made for kids but it did have
disturbing imagery and I did see it a
lot as a kid things crawled in their
ears of this so what a world where a lot
of things are clean and if there's
violence is clean violence this movie
comes out its kind of gross the villains
are gross the concepts of grossest
everything is just dirty but fun in that
family kind of way I feel like this is
one of those movies I would take my kid
to see knowing that I'd probably mess
him up a little bit ever like
way too young for this or that being
said don't tell your mom come on if I
had kids it's out go down it's probably
why I don't have kids in the end the
boxtrolls was a pretty fun time for me I
think adults are gonna enjoy it
especially for the animation ability
remember Nightmare Before Christmas I
grew up on that and that's this is cool
the stage the fact it has smart humor
that hits well they're gonna like that
kids are gonna be entertained if not
freaked out from the movie and that's
good the first half is slower than the
second half the second half is longer
than the first half at all and I'm not
gonna complain about the boxtrolls
because the boxtrolls is a pretty good
time no alcohol required person when you
were a kid what was the thing that
freaked you out mine easy freaked me out
I would look at the like when a door is
open you know between the hinge of the
door and the wall there's that space out
vision him there in my wall just like
that staring at me freaks me I don't
know why I did that to myself so
whatever your childhood movie fear is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more